Well,
I think the one thing that disciplined
definitely does help you with is it
helps you get things done and when you
get things done,
when you,
you actually do things,
you,
you have more success.
If you have more success and sometimes a
big part of success is just not being
fucking lazy and just doing it,
just get.
That's like 90 percent of it is just
showing up,
get there and start working.
Like you're not going to feel perfect
every day.
If I felt,
if I only worked out when I felt good,
I'd be a fat fuck because there's a lot
of days I don't want to do it.
I've,
it's pretty much the same with everybody
that if that actually gets good at
something that you get,
there's got to be those days you pushed
through and they're the,
they're probably going to be more
numerous than the days you don't.
And so the benefit of discipline in my
eyes has always been that through
discipline I get things done.
I always tell them,
I always say that I'm like the most lazy
disciplined person I know because I
don't want to do it.
Yeah,
but I always do.
One of the big problems is sitting down
and doing the work and you,
you gotta an pressfield talks about that
in the most concise and beautiful way
and he labels it like an enemy.
He calls it resistance,
you know,
and that you have to sit down and you
have to overcome resistance and that the
pro goes to work and it doesn't matter
if you're sick.
It doesn't matter if you have kids.
It doesn't matter what you,
you're a pro and you go to work and that
and that just it puts it in your head
that this is what I do and this is when
you have pride in that and then when you
are in front of that keyboard and
you're,
you got,
you look down the count,
it says,
I fuck a thousand words today.
I put a thousand words and you and you,
you,
you're doing the work and out of that
work,
gems,
blossom,
little things.
But you might have a day where you just
write nothing but dog shit.
So what?
Show up again tomorrow and tomorrow out
of that dark,
she had a flower emerge.
You never know.
And that's the only way to develop real,
like to,
to really develop your potential 100
percent in anything,
whether it's as an author or even as a
martial artist,
there's a lot of creativity in martial
arts.
To be a great striker,
you have to be creative because you have
to,
you have to develop patterns or execute
patterns that are,
aren't going to be perceived.
This idea that life is hard,
something you're supposed to shield from
them.
It's so silly.
And you know,
I've had this conversation with my
friends because,
uh,
everybody that I know that's interesting
how to fucked up life.
But,
but now we have kids and the last thing
we want is our kids to have a fucked up
life.
So we put our kids in these good
schools.
We live in these nice neighborhoods.
Everybody eats healthy and there's no
fucking domestic violence.
And everybody seems it's so different
than all of our lives.
And we were talking about it,
me and Brian Calendar actually talking
about it,
like,
look,
we all had fucked up childhoods and
everybody we know had fucked up
childhoods and they're all interesting,
but I don't want my kids to be boring,
but I also want them to be safe.
So it's like,
how do you,
how do you approach that?
I think you get involved is what I've
chosen to do is get my kids involved in
martial arts and,
and,
and give them the opportunity to pursue
difficult things and understanding that
through pursuing these difficult things,
like in accomplishing stuff like you,
you learn something about yourself,
you learn that you have this ability
inside of you to overcome,
get obsessed with life improvement,
find things that you enjoy doing.
They're difficult.
Do them and get better.
It seems so simplistic.
It seems like a ridiculous idealistic
point of view,
but it's effective.
Well,
you need some form,
some amount of pride and some amount of
ego to get good at things in the first
place because it's such a
counterintuitive notion because you have
to have a belief in yourself.
You have to be able,
like when you,
when you first,
when you start out at Jujitsu,
your white belt,
like I remember being a white belt and
being like,
oh my God,
I am fucking never going to get good at
this.
I'm going to suck forever.
But to,
to,
to look at people who are better than
you and no,
they had to have sucked at one point in
time.
Okay,
this guy be somewhere along the end of
this tunnel.
There's got to be a light.
I just got to keep going.
Yeah,
and that takes ego.
Ego drives,
you know you to be successful.
Me To be successful.
Egos.
What's driving you?
The problem is when you let it go too
far and you know everything,
you know,
everything takes balance.
There's a dichotomy and everything.
Every part of you has a dichotomy.
You know,
you can get so into the physical aspects
of things that you end up like doing a
bunch of steroids and going crazy and
ruining your health.
That's not good.
The other end of the spectrum,
you know,
you can sit around and play video games
and turned into a
bodybuilding is a great example of that
because when you start lifting weights
like,
God,
I'd like to be stronger and you start
getting a little bit bigger.
You're like,
oh look at that,
I got a muscle,
Ooh,
this is cool,
and then you keep going and then you
keep going.
But some guys get so fucking crazy they
won't stop until they have 22 inch arms
and they want to have thighs that are so
big.
They have to walk like they're,
they've got a barrel in between their
legs and you know,
and they,
they just can't help but they just take
it to some completely unhealthy place.
Yeah,
that's rough.
Yeah.
Well,
it's,
it's just the nature of trying to get
good at something.
You've got to recognize what's good and
what is just fucking insane.
For some people especially,
they're just experiencing way too much
pressure and that pressure.
A lot of times it's just a,
an imbalanced and perspective and some
of it's in like a,
I was talking to this,
mom wants,
her daughter does gymnastics with my
daughter and we were talking about um,
kids killing themselves where she used
to live.
She still live in,
um,
one of the really wealthy tech areas
outside of San Francisco and a bunch of
kids that went to school with her
daughter that were like 15,
16.
We're jumping off bridges and shit.
Like it was a,
like an epidemic and they were trying to
figure out what the fuck is going on.
And they're literally calling it
Affluenza.
That these affluent kids and their
families are literally worth a billion
dollars.
You know,
I mean,
everybody's super rich and they're
having this insane pressure like before
high school and in high school to be an
Ivy League schools and to get four
point,
oh,
and they're fucking,
they're not having any fun and they're
not experienced in life and they don't
have any hope.
And their parents are all on fucking
pills and they're just killing
themselves for some people out there
that aren't feeling good.
Man,
if you just fucking struggled more,
you get over that struggle,
you feel better.
It sounds so simplistic,
but I swear by it,
I felt shitty myself and then force
myself to work out.
Then after I get out of there,
I'm like,
Whoa,
100 percent guarantee.
It's hard for people to break momentum
to momentum.
That's good.
Momentum or momentum.
Momentum is bad.
Momentum.
When I get a,
like when I get on a good groove of
working out all the time,
I feel like after I'm done working out,
I'm like,
I can't wait to get in there again.
I can't wait to work out again.
That's the good momentum,
but then there's that bad momentum,
like you get injured or something like
that and you can't do anything for a
couple of weeks and then to try to get
that kickstart,
that meant motor up again.
It's,
it's hard to get momentum.
There's a lot of people that are eating
shit food and then by the end of the day
your body's in a crisis.
You're body's just processing all this
bullshit and if you're eating a big like
bullshit lunch filled with nonsense,
like your body's got to process all that
stuff,
and so at the end of the day,
yeah,
you're going to lose your willpower.
So like when 5:00,
6:00 rolls around,
you're going to be tired,
but if you have a healthy lunch and you
know you're,
you're properly fueled and then you also
have positive people in your life,
everyone's motivated by the end of the
day,
you're going to feel good.
Whatever the fuck you thing is,
just go and do it.
Just force yourself to do it.
And if you feel like shit because you
ate lunch,
then your lunch was filled with
bullshit.
Well then,
hey dummy,
don't eat shitty lunch tomorrow,
tomorrow.
Try a nice salad,
a salad with some salmon and see how you
feel.
Then you're like,
hey,
I feel way better today at 6:00 dot.
Yeah.
Now your decision making will be better
like that.
People don't understand how significant
it is,
like all these little decisions,
they,
those are the.
That's the path for the rest of your
existence on earth,
and if you decide to go to fucking
cheetos,
chocolate chip cookie route,
you're.
If you're just making a shit path,
you're carving and your fucking path
through broken rocks and glass and it's
not the way to go.
You know what else doesn't exist in a
day to day life,
a place where it's okay to be a man.
It's actually okay to be a man.
It's okay to have man thoughts like
everybody is so,
so toned down and neutered.
It's like human resources and corporate
life has watered down people's natural
behavior to the point where people are
just dying on the inside,
sitting in these fucking cubicles
rotting,
just freaking the fuck out.
Having all these thoughts,
they can entertain having to pretend to
be someone there.
They are not all day long putting on
this bullshit way of talking,
this fake way of thinking.
Everybody's got a subscribe to whatever
fucking ridiculous policies their
company wants to enforce and you're just
a robot and you get out of there and you
just want to scream.
It's this fear of discomfort.
People have this extreme feeling in
their mind when it comes to their
associations with exercise.
They want to avoid discomfort.
They feel like anytime exercise is just
like something to be avoided,
that's not for me.
Fuck that.
I don't want to sweat.
I don't want to strain,
and a lot of times this association that
they have is about the beginnings of
getting in shape.
It's not about once you're actually fit
because once you're actually fit,
exercise is something you look forward
to.
It's an alleviation of stress.
It's.
It feels great.
Like if I can't get a workout in,
I look at my schedule,
I go,
ah Shit.
I don't have any time for a workout,
which means I'm not going to get that
good feeling,
and so instead of looking at it like,
oh,
I've got to go grant and sweat,
I'm thinking I'm not going to feel good.
I'm not going to feel relaxed.
I'm not going to feel carefree and I'm
not going to feel even appreciative.
Like my appreciation of things.
It gets enhanced greatly after exercise.
I just feel better.
I feel like I can take things in for
what they are rather than,
you know,
whatever the weather was,
sensory data that I'm getting from any
event is just one more distraction that
gets in my way.
And,
and know that that's a lot of times how
I look at things if I'm overstressed or
if I'm working too much like our bodies
for whatever reason,
uh,
most people,
their associations are to avoid anything
that's uncomfortable.
But it's so illogical because when you
look at comfort and you look at success
and progress and the eventual,
the feelings of accomplishment and of
getting past certain hurdles and in
terms of like how you feel about life,
a lot of those are connected to
discomfort.
Discomfort is your friend.
It really is like discomfort and,
and not being happy and content with
certain situations in life or certain
feelings in life.
There are massive,
massive motivators and they're,
they're amazing at,
at facilitating change.
And yet our instinct is to avoid those
and just sit on the couch and watch some
fucking reality show about dudes who
make moonshine with our jaw open bazaar.
And for me,
at least,
when I get,
when I get like really disciplined and
really,
um,
I get really consistent with my
workouts.
One of the things that I feel,
I almost feel momentum.
I feel like there's like a push behind
me.
Like,
all right,
we're,
you know,
like after I get out of the gym,
I have a really good workout.
I'm like,
yeah,
now I'm doing it.
I'm doing it all the time now.
And I'm looking forward to the next
time.
And it makes resistance much weaker and
it makes my motivation and my discipline
much stronger.
I think a lot of it is based on just the
consistency,
you know,
it's one of the things that I talked
about recently on the podcast.
I said,
you know,
like blowing something off.
It's not just not like blowing off a of
an exercise that you planned is not just
bad for you physically.
It's also bad mentally because then that
option is now available.
The option to fuck off is available and
you did it before and you're probably
going to do it again and you'll get
mediocre results.
Not just in that aspect of your life,
but maybe in all aspects of your life
because I think that option to fuck off
when you embrace it,
that is a pathway that you might choose
when it comes to dealing with conflict
in your personal life,
dealing with business decisions,
dealing with career decisions,
like an uncomfortable decision that you
might be faced with when you maybe you
need to make a change as far as what
your pathway is in life,
but you don't do it instead you fuck off
and that the inclination to fuck off.
I think that gathers momentum as well.
The inclination to be disciplined.
That comes with momentum too and I think
both things like you did,
you take a path,
the path of the healthy person or the
path of the fuck off like this is not
like your body is like a race car that
you can juice up yourself.
Like you can add the fat tires,
you can add the improve suspension.
You can beef up the horsepower in the
engine.
You could do all that yourself or you
could just choose to have this shitty
body that's always falling apart on you
because we're essentially ecosystems,
you know,
and we're,
we're in charge.
This weird consciousness that has all
this resistance and has all this
inclination towards comfort and fucking
off and blowing things off is what is in
charge of making all these things happen
that keep this ecosystem healthy.
It's almost like if earth itself had
like a shitty manager,
you know,
if there was a manager of a natural
manager of earth that was like,
Oh God,
who cares if it rains?
you know,
like,
let's let you know I'm,
I'm going to stop growing things.
I don't give a shit anymore.
It's all stupid anyway.
I mean,
it's literally like the,
the,
just blow it up.
Fuck it.
Let's just kill all the life will do.
It's all going to die eventually.
I mean,
the sun only lasts 7 billion years.
You see?
That is the perspective a lot of people
take with Adrian where it's like,
well,
if you're going to die,
you're going to age.
You can't stop aging.
And it's like,
yes,
you're right,
but that's not the point.
The point is to age better.
Like that's the point.
The point is to increase your health
span,
you know?
And that is,
we know is possible like that can.
There's some,
there's some of these like centenarians
and Supercentenarians I've seen that are
like,
you know,
over 100 years old and they're like
riding bikes and racing and it's like
they're old,
they're very old,
they're experiencing got a
very good quality of and experiencing a
quality of life that these other people
that don't exercise feel they physically
feel their own body diminishing and they
just feel it's inevitable.
It's just,
it is what it is.
You're wasting your time.
You're out there running around.
But no we're not because this experience
right now,
it's not like no one's under the
illusion that you're gonna live forever,
but you are enhancing the experience
that you're currently involved in right
now and you are alive.
You are alive.
You do experience this life.
But do you experience this life
optimally?
Is it,
is it as enjoyable as it can be?
And we all know that there's a spectrum
for that enjoyability,
like we've all had times in our life
where it's not been so great and then
times in a life where everything came
together like what a fucking great day,
Woo.
Like make more of those.
Like you could make more of those and
then the whole things better.
And I think when that whole thing is
better,
it affects everybody.
You touch everybody that's around you,
everybody you come in contact with and
that in turn,
I mean it sounds so grandiose,
but in,
in turn can affect the entire race of
human beings.
I've always wondered if the depression
that people see in mass today,
there's so much depression that people.
I mean there's a ca.
It's a common trait.
Like it's a common condition.
Oh,
he suffers from depression.
she suffers from depression.
Like,
oh,
he's got herpes.
You know?
You know what I mean?
It's like,
it's a,
it's a common thing.
I've always wondered or I've been
wondering more and more recently,
it really hit me when have you ever seen
a Heimos Arctic adventure?
This guy lives in this incredibly remote
area of the Arctic National Wildlife
Refuge in the Alaskan interior and he.
He lives in this really small log cabin
and he hunts and gathers and that's all
he does and he's very smart.
Like he's not a dummy at all and he's
been up there.
He lives with his wife and his.
He raised children up there and it's
really,
really.
There's some dark moments and there
because they lived like this from the
time,
like when they had children up there and
they lost their two year old baby in a
fucking canoe.
Like they tipped over in a,
in a canoe and lost their kid and it's
like it's really intense when they
revisit the site and leave flowers and
it was like 30 years ago and they had
several children since then.
But this moment is still like this
intense moment of loss for them where
they lost their baby.
But this fucking guy is very happy and
very,
very smart and very connected and very
articulate.
And he firmly believes that human
beings.
When we evolved and developed and were
hunter gatherers that there's a set of
rewards,
there's reward systems that are set up
inside the human body,
inside the,
the,
the very being that we embody that don't
get met in today's society and it's one
of the things that's causing depression.
One of the things that's causing this
funk that people are in is that we're
living our lives.
Many of us,
at least in these very unfulfilling ways
where you're going to this office with
artificial light and you're doing
something you don't want to do all day
long and then you get home and you're
tired and on top of that you're eating
shit.
You're eating potato chips and you're
drinking soda and your body is just
like,
what in the fuck is this?
We're supposed to be out in the fields
were supposed to be walking up hills.
We're supposed to be looking for animals
or gathering vegetables.
We're supposed to be doing all these
things that our body's designed to do.
We're supposed to be in nature and
nature is like a medicine.
Like it literally is a medicine to you,
like people.
People that go,
you don't have to go hunting,
you don't have to go fishing,
just go fucking hike,
man.
Just go hike up to the top of a mountain
and look out,
you know,
there's a reward that you get from that
that is intensely like soul filling.
Just like something about like when I
was in Colorado and there was this,
this area of boulder where you drive up
one of these roads and there's this area
where you could park and it was this
incredible view,
man.
These people just park and just go out
there and just look,
but you get there and you park and you
go,
fuck [inaudible].
You would see you.
You literally seen the continental
divide.
These snow capped mountains in July,
July.
It's covered with snow because those
mountains don't give a perspective.
Oh,
just this whole new perspective on it
and I think nature,
I think the ease of suffering is always
in present.
This,
you know,
when you're in president is truly locked
in in presidents.
There is no suffering.
There can be pain,
but no suffering.
Suffering isn't.
It's something created by our own minds
and I think nature is one of the great
ways to do this because humans,
we,
we learned,
we take cues from our environment and
nature,
as I was saying earlier,
is always in the present.
You know,
there's this natural presidents of all
the animals,
everything around you.
Whereas if you get around a bunch of
people watching housewives and stressed
about this and popping pills,
you're going to take on that energy too
and you're going to lose your president
is because of your surroundings.
So it's like this ultimate regrounding
tool where we get back to a present
moment,
you know,
and that's such a fucking key element to
human happiness.
And I think the other key element is
having something where we're fighting
for,
you know,
having them mission.
I think we're all forces and that forest
needs to have an effect,
needs to have a reason that it's moving
in a certain direction.
And I think with all of our meats and
all of our needs met,
you know,
where we don't have to hunt for food,
we don't have to acquire everything.
Everything's relatively easy and it's
all about advancement and all this.
We've lost a lot of the basic mission,
which was the mission to survive and
procreate,
you know,
so.
And we haven't replaced it with any
other universal mission,
which is I think one of the big allures
of these things like wars and these
things like creating an enemy.
Well at least then you have a mission
and when you have a mission,
human beings are happy.
You know,
like a birch and Russell talked about he
but conquest of happiness and he had his
own fucked up attributes.
Every time I bring them up,
people talk about is fucked up.
And as he thought he was into phrenology
and he might've been racist,
whatever,
but he was a good philosopher.
Smoked constantly.
But.
But anyways,
he talked about the happiest person he
knew.
The happiest person he could find was a
groundskeeper on a manner who every day
woke up and was at war with the rabbits.
Have the guy.
He just declared that the rabbits were
the fucking enemy.
And he would go out with his gun and he
would hunt as many as possible.
And he'd go morning till till night and
he would kill as many rabbits as he
could because it was the rabbits were
the ones eating the hedges and the
flowers and whatever.
So he basically made the rabbits as
enemy and struck out every single day to
kill as many rabbits as possible.
And that dude,
according to Bertrand Russell,
was happy as fuck.
He had a task,
he had a task,
he had a purpose,
you know,
you had a mission.
My mission is to destroy the rabbits.
I just have a dog like that.
Yeah.
I had the happiest dog ever.
His name was Frank Sinatra.
And uh,
he was a pit bull that all he lived for
was killing lizards and my house,
my old house,
not the house of it now,
but my old house had this one,
um,
it's like a on a hill and there's this
one wall where these lizards would run
up the wall.
And so frank,
I would literally let him out in the
morning and he fucking bolt out that
door,
like time to go to war.
And he would run and go look for these
lizards.
And he would stand there like Eddie
Bravo would just watch it and marvel.
He be like,
fuck man,
this dog does this every day there's doc
does this.
Every day I go,
this is what he loves to do.
And he would go there and he would have
his paws on the wall.
Are you
crazy?
He would jump up and try to grab a
lizard and occasionally he would get one
and he'd be like,
fuck yeah.
And he would get one.
They would go looking for another one.
He would go and he was a pretty big yard
so he would go wandering around the yard
looking for anything else at fucked up.
Anything else that was slipping?
It was constantly,
unfortunately twice.
I had to take him to the hospital
because he got bit by rattlesnakes
because rattlesnakes are slipping to.
Apparently he killed the rattlesnakes,
but the rattlesnakes fucked him up here.
Like a water balloon.
Go the other side of his head.
Both of my dogs.
By the way.
That's a real problem.
If you don't have the money to pay for
the serum,
it's super expensive.
It was several thousand dollars to treat
them for this rattlesnake venom.
Antivenom.
Shit.
It's like,
I was like,
man,
what if I was poor?
What if a.
that's a whole fucked up system like
you.
They inject horses with the Venom and
they'd get the antibodies from the
horses.
It's this archaic system.
I think my friend Donald Schultz is
working on.
He's a big snake handler guy.
He's working on ways to innovate around
that because it's kind of like a real
backwards system that they have.
How you get antivenom?
Well,
a horse will survive,
so let's just fucking sorta put the
venom in there and then we'll get the
antibodies from the horse and then you
know,
it's,
it's a weird.
It's a weird thing how they do it.
Yeah.
Well that's a real problem with people
that are vegans.
If you're a Vegan,
you don't use any animal products.
He a bit by a rattlesnake.
You got two choices.
Compromise your morals or that's a wrap,
you know,
but this dog was so goddamn happy.
He had missions,
you know,
he would go out of that yard.
He wasn't bored.
He was pleased to me for a walk.
Come on man.
He was like,
see a dude,
don't open that door with God.
He's just had his little mission and I
think you can see that in the people who
are the most unhappy.
They seem aimless.
Like,
what am I here for?
Why am I doing this?
Nothing makes sense.
You know,
and I've even felt it in my own life
when,
you know,
I know what my mission here is for my
mission is to expand human consciousness
to help people be happy.
That's really what I find my greatest
purpose in.
But every once in a while I'll get this
kind of like,
fuck people attitude.
Maybe someone said some fucked up shit
and I'm like,
man,
people fucking suck for people.
And then at that moment that's when I'm
actually impressed because I've lost my
mission.
Instead of having a mission like yes,
my mission is human consciousness,
all of a sudden it's like fuck people,
fuck that mission.
They'll figure it out and then I'm
depressed because I've lost my purpose.
It's very hard to rise above like
literally when something like that
happens and realize like,
Oh,
you've just,
you're,
you're encountering one diseased
individual.
You've got to look at the mass of
humanity.
Like when you encounter one diseased
individual,
it's so like this guy who shot up that
nightclub in Orlando,
you're,
you're looking at one disease individual
and if you say,
man,
people fucking suck.
Look what they did.
We'll look at how many people that are
responding with rainbows on their
twitter pages and love and,
and all the best wishes to those folks
that got killed and other.
I mean it was looking at this guy's
paid.
She was an animal lover who is
organizing people to go to the homes of
the victims and see if they have pets or
travel.
You know,
there's this beautiful people out there.
Yeah,
there's a lot.
There's more beautiful pete.
This,
this is what that is out a doubt.
Not just the safest.
The easiest is the happiest time in
terms of like being able to like reach
out and,
and,
and send love to people and have people
send love to you,
but it's just occasionally you run into
concert in the concert itself,
but the beauty is out there too.
It's just not as dramatic and it doesn't
impose upon us as forcefully,
but we,
if we just look,
it's around all the time.
We run into good people all the time,
but you just make eye contact with that
person or that kid is just looking at
you and just create that little smile
and you're like,
oh yeah,
the good of humanity.
The fact that,
you know,
we really are love,
being expressed outwardly all the time
and it's just these other delusions that
get in the way of that.
Well,
we're oddly attracted to negativity to.
It's almost like we look at negativity
online or that you run into is like
possibility of war.
Like,
yeah,
I feel like I'll just fucking drums
beating.
Goddammit.
There's an army on the background.
They're coming,
they're coming,
but you know,
it's like there's this real impulse to
sort of batten down the hatches on
really it's just some fucking 36 year
old losers sitting in his parents
basement,
you know,
farting and smelling his own farts and
angry online.
I mean,
that's really what a lot of you're
dealing with.
You're dealing with really sick people,
like people that have just,
for whatever reason,
they've not found their path.
They've not found any happiness.
They have found any fulfillment.
They don't.
They haven't found any growth there just
stifled or rotten and some sort of a
weird way.
It just hasn't really worked for them
and so they're,
they're lashing out,
lashing out at the world and you run
into one of those people suck and that's
the initial response and then the more
conscious response is to look at and be
and have compassion for that person.
That is hard to do and our system isn't
based upon that.
And even if you look at the US penal
system,
it's very much about punishment.
Whereas you watched that documentary
that Michael Morton who to invade nest
where they go to Norway,
they have a whole different idea of what
the penal system is for.
It's about restoring human dignity and
cultivating a change.
Really making change in the person.
It's not about punishment.
It's about.
It's about actually changing that
individual so he doesn't do it again,
and then you look at the recidivism
rates between our prisons and Norway's
prisons and they're just dramatically
different.
That impulse to punish immediately,
you know,
is not the healthiest impulse.
That's just gonna create more issues
down the road.
You're not rehabilitating anybody.
You're just taking even more broken
people and putting them out in the world
and hoping they're not going to do the
broken thing.
Well,
it's not going to fucking work.
You know the right impulse is always
that compassion and looking to see as if
that was you.
How all of these fucked up elements of
the world and choices.
I'm not overriding the fact that they
had choices and all this.
They're not free of guilt,
but look at,
look at that like this is the person
that just made some bad choices and had
some tough shit to deal with and
couldn't overcome it.
The resistance in the video game was
higher than his skillset and he wasn't
able to,
to choose to work and choose to the
positive elements that would allow them
to overcome it,
you know?
Yeah.
It's,
it's also Norway's dealing with far
fewer people,
you know,
and that's,
that's a good thing for them.
And it's also they don't have that
conquers mentality that we have.
So we're so wrapped up in success and
also in punishment.
I mean that,
that is a big aspect of our culture,
like punishment.
And I mean like when anyone does
anything wrong online,
the amount of people that feel like it's
their job to shame that person and
embarrass that person and an insult,
that person,
it's pretty crazy to watch when
something goes down.
It's also,
it's also counterproductive,
you know?
And,
and I see that in the people shaming
people for appropriation,
right?
So let's say for example,
someone wears a head dress at a fucking
festival,
right?
They're probably mildly.
They're not doing it to mock the native
Americans,
most likely,
probably like a,
a mild appreciation and interest.
I think this looks cool.
I'm in a place and you know,
and then all of a sudden they get all
this intense hate and shame and putting
all of this stuff,
all of these intentions on them that
weren't true.
Again,
going back to my point about morality,
it's not about the act,
it's about the intentions of the eye,
but right now we make it all about the
act.
Oh,
you wore this headdress.
That means you're insulting thousands of
years of native Americans.
You're oppressing,
you're appropriating like,
no,
I fucking wasn't.
I was wearing a fucking Harris'
headdress.
But then all of a sudden that imprint
will create trauma and that trauma will
have a poisonous impact that will make
them feel weird and make them want to do
that to other people.
So it's like you're in injecting someone
with a,
like a heat virus,
you know,
that they're going to then pass on to
other people rather than doing the
opposite,
you know,
spreading the love.
Herpes were contagious positivity that
goes the other way.
And we have those choices with how to
deal with people.
But more often than not,
we come with this thing to punish and
create more trauma which triggers their
own self judge and their own self hate,
lowers their own self love.
And then they're going to pass that off
to kids,
family members,
people around them.
You know,
there's just two sets of dominoes that
we can choose to take to take either
path.